Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Yunus ASIK
(Alkış)
Merhaba.
Öyle güzel görünüyorsunuz ki,
buradan kendinizi görmenizi isterim.
Hafiften dizlerim titremedi değil,
yani itiraf edeyim.
(Alkış)
Zaman zaman düşünürüm
ve kendimi mutlu hissederim
ve şanslı olduğumu düşündüğüm
için mutlu hissederim.
Çünkü hayatım boyunca, çok
sevdiğim bir işi yaparak yaşadım.
Hayatımı işimle kazandım.
Beni ben yapan, mesleğim oldu.
Giderek, o mesleğe aşık oldum,
yani sinema benim aşkım oldu.
Ben diyorum ki, derim ki,
kendinize bir ''aşk'' seçin.
Ben hangi meslekte mutlu
olurum, diye düşünün.
Tabii sonra o mesleği, o aşkı, yani
ona giderek aşkla bağlanacaksınız,
o aşkı beslemek lazım.
Onun için düş gücünüzü
özgür bırakın, diyorum.
Düş gücünü zenginleştirmek,
geliştirmek için,
çok farklı alanlarda, farklı konularda
bilgi sahibi olmak, dünyamızı genişletir,
vizyonumuzu genişletir, büyütür.
Zaten sanat, edebiyat,
bilim bunun için var.
Mesela bir müzik, bir roman,
bir şiir, hatta bir cümle bile
hani ufkumuza ışık tutabilir,
bizi harekete geçirir.
Tüm bunlar bizim başarılı
olmamızı sağlar, diyorum.
Yani yaptığınız iş ne olursa olsun,
belki sevmediğiniz bir iş de olabilir,
onu sevebilecek hale getirmeye çalışmak,
onu eğlenceli bir hale getirmeye çalışmak,
gerekir diye düşünüyorum, o zaman
giderek o tutku, o mesleğe o aşk başlıyor.
Bu arada, size beni çok etkileyen
bir anektodu anlatmak istiyorum.
Madam Curie, hepiniz biliyorsunuzdur,
bir Polonyalı, ünlü bilim insanı.
Gece gündüz laboratuvardan
çıkmayıp deliler gibi çalışıyormuş.
Bir gün, kendisi gibi bilim insanı
olan kocası dayanamamış.
Yeter artık ara ver, biraz
dışarı çık, biraz eğlen, demiş.
Madam Curie'nin cevabı:
''Ama sen beni anlamıyorsun ki.
Ben çok, ben burada en çok
burada eğleniyorum,'' demiş.
Bu beni o kadar etkilemiş
bir hikâyedir ki.
Bazı meslekler vardır böyle,
sıkıcı ve zor görünür.
Ama bazı meslekler de,
aman ne kolay falan denir,
yani eğlenceli.
Benim mesleğim belki hani dışarıdan
kolay ve eğlenceli gelebilir
ama benim için eğlenceli
ama bir o kadar da zor inanın.
Düşünün, kendiniz olmayan bir karakteri
sıfırdan bir karakter yaratıyorsunuz.
Yani, ister inanın ister inanmayın ama
birçok geceler, yani bir iki karakterin,
bazı karakterleri yaratmak için birçok
geceler kanlı gözyaşları döktüğüm olmuştur
ama daha sonra, o başarıyla tabii,
büyük bir mutluluk yaşıyorsunuz.
Altmış yedi senesi zannediyorum,
ünlü hani çok bilinen ''Çalıkuşu''
romanının filmini çekiyoruz,
ilk ''Çalıkuşu''nda ben
oynamıştım Feride rolünde.
Şimdi rahmetli olan sevgili,
filmin yönetmeni Osman Seden
bir sahnede, bir replik vardı.
Bak Türkan, bu repliğin çok değerini
vererek, yani çok iyi oyna, dedi.
Replik şuydu:
''Sevgi ve şevkat denen şeyde,
ne mucizeler var yarabbi.''
Bu beni çok etkilemişti,
inanın bana hayatım boyunca,
benim rehberim oldu adeta.
Bütün çevirdiğim sevgi dolu, aşk dolu
filmlerde, belki özel hayatımda da,
sevgi ve şevkat hep
duyumsadığım duygular oldu.
Aradan yıllar geçti, sevgili
rahmetli Atıf Yılmaz ile
''Selvi Boylum Al Yazmalım''
diye bir film çevirdik.
Oradaki bir sözcük de sevgi
sözcüğüne yepyeni bir boyut getirdi.
Belki birçoğunuz biliyorsunuzdur,
sevgi emektir.
(Alkış)
Yani sonra düşünüyorum ben, bu
mesleğim benim okulum olmuş,
bana zenginlik kazandırmış, yani belki de
şunu söylemek lazım, ne kadar aşkla
bir işi, bir mesleği yaparsanız, o kadar
güzel mi dönüyor acaba size?
Yani adanmışlık, kendinizi adamak,
benim hayatta hep önceliğim mesleğim oldu.
Onun da çok güzel karşılığını
aldım diye düşünüyorum.
(Alkış)
Benim için sihirli bir söz olan, o sevgi
sözcüğüyle sizlere veda edeyim.
Sevginin olduğu her yerde,
her şey çok güzel olur.
Sevgiyle yaşayın, sevgiyle
kalın, sizi seviyorum.
(Alkış)
Teşekkür ederim.